Oh my
gosh.
Thank you for the welcome.
Super thank you!
Here is Day Old Red Envelope.
Happy Lunar New Year!
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome to Norowareta DigiCamp!
The Cursed DigiCamp.
Does anybody call it a DigiCamp?
They just call it a camera, right?
Why isn't it just called the Cursed Camera?
I don't know.
Lampy, thanks for the gift dude!
Your best side, you're my best view.
Bye Roblox!
Thank you for the welcome.
Happy Lunar New Year!
Happy Lunar New Year.
Oh my gosh.
My best side...
My best side I would say is this side.
Actually I don't know.
Maybe this side.
I don't know.
Which side?
I think you see more of my cheeks on this side.
You know what?
I like the view.
You're my best view.
I might be quoting that a lot tonight.
To keep myself sane.
I'm scared!
Notification didn't go off.
Now I'm late.
You're just in time.
We just started.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Andreyko, thanks for the 20!
DigiCamp makes me think of Marpat, Digital Camo.
Did you get tricked into playing Metal Gear?
I wish!
I wish this was Metal Gear.
My best friend thinks I'm addicted to you.
Yeah, he's not trying hard enough.
So true.
I don't know.
How do you convince someone to watch someone?
I'm not everybody's taste probably.
Probably like she's a little too freaky.
She's a little... She gets a little too wackadoodle out there I'd say.
It's my friend Mon's birthday!
They really love you.
I mean it a lot.
If you could sing them happy birthday.
Have fun, Minto!
Pure randomness, you're such a good friend!
I will sing happy birthday to Mon!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mon!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
So this is the new Chilla's Art Game, right?
I guess it's the newest.
It's been out for a little bit.
I watched some clips of Oli from Hello ID freaking out about some stuff.
About the game.
It seems kind of scary.
It seems so much more... It looks much better than usual Chilla's Art Game.
I don't know so much about it though.
Hello baby girl.
I hope you've been well and freaky.
I'm always freaky.
Saku!
Oh my gosh it's been a while.
Did you see they uploaded the Netflix DMC?
I did!
Did you guys see the new Devil May Cry opening?
Oh my gosh it's Limp Bizkit!
I can't believe it!
Oh my gosh.
I was like...
I was like no way.
I think this is made for me.
No way!
Yeah, you're going to have to watch the new... It's such a cool looking opening too.
It actually feels so Devil May Cry.
Best OP choice ever.
I did not expect it at all.
In fact I didn't really catch the song, what the song was until the chorus.
Then I was like, I haven't heard this song in so long!
I remember it so vividly to like Katamari.
Like seeing AMVs of that song to Katamari so long ago.
I got my bachelors degree this week!
Nashi!
Congratulations!
I don't know...
Little Minky is up to give you lots of courage today.
Thank you!
I need it!
You're pretty good.
Thanks Micmac.
Why isn't the emoji working?
Why didn't it work?
In the super chat.
YouTube, what the heck.
Lulugaming, thank you for 9 months!
Throwing out there that the new Netflix Devil May Cry anime OP release.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm excited to watch it.
And I saw ladies in the opening too.
Ducky, thanks for the 5k!
Live streams look weird on YouTube now.
How do they look?
Do they?
Do they look weird?
Maybe you're being... Oh my gosh.
I thought my Twitter was broken.
And instead I got specially selected for one of the UI updates.
And so now everything looks terrible.
I don't want to be selected.
I want to be opted out please.
Albaro, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
So, yeah.
Opt out of Twitter.
I wish.
I wish I could.
I have too many idols.
Everything is there.
It's hard for me to just opt out.
Thank you for being a super wonderful freaky self.
Thank you!
Tiss himself, thanks for the 5 gifted.
Paperbacks, thanks for the 5 gifted.
I guess I should get it.
I guess I should just play this now.
It looks so scary.
Okay, I will be brave.
I will be brave.
I might be... I think there is like a bootleg Mickey Mouse in this.
I gotta make some jokes to get me through.
Hi, thanks for the 5 gifted.
I know I'm a ghost too, but like...
You see me in the maid cafe.
You don't see me haunting a little creepy playground.
That's weird.
I don't mess with those kinds of ghosts.
We don't mess with the Mickey Mouse ghost.
That's the legally distinct Mickey Mouse.
I'm in a maid cafe.
I'm that kind of freak.
I'm not a freak in the children's... the playground.
No, that's not my freak.
And I don't mess with the freak.
Steamboat willy.
That's just what it's called.
The Inky and the Minky Machine.
Wait, what was that game called?
Dottie Blot and the...
And the Inky World.
What was it called?
Bendy and the... No, it's not a Minky.
Bendy and the Inky Machine.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah, Bendy... Stop saying Minky.
Bendy and the Inky Machine.
That one.
That's the ghosty Steamboat Willy.
The OP borrowed things from DMC3 manga.
There's a manga even?
Why didn't Metal Gear get a manga?
When is Metal Gear getting an anime?
I know people will be upset about it though, because they're going to be like, it's going to suck.
People will be upset about everything.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Metal Gear got novels, true.
They'd ruin it.
I don't know.
I don't know if they'd ruin it.
I feel though that maybe it wouldn't translate well.
Like in terms of art style.
MGS live action, which will never happen.
It will never happen.
OK, new game!
Can I move?
No.
How's the audio?
It's my right ear.
Start!
My daughter died in our local park.
I cannot sleep since then.
She torments me every day and night.
Wait, is she missing or did she die?
She is still bound to this world.
I must free her.
Oh my god, she's just like me for real for real.
Look at this picture on the left of her going down the slide.
Get her a bigger jacket she can't raise her arms up.
She's outgrown it.
It looks so forced.
She is no longer here with me.
Lost spirit liberation method.
Try not to get scared.
Scariest stories.
My daughter died in the local park.
It was the daughter killing park.
Lost spirit liberation method actually sounds like a Metal Gear mission though, I'm not gonna lie.
This is one of those games I've been avoiding on other Vtubers to watch you play specifically.
Do your worst.
Oh gosh, OK.
Is this actually fatal frame?
If it is, I will be scared.
After some searching, I found a website perfect for my needs.
Is this my house?
What is this?
A website that allows a lingering spirit to be liberated.
Me?
Actually me?
Maybe?
Sorry, should I put my arm down?
I wonder if it will get in the way of the subtitles.
The website states, take pictures of your deceased loved one with a camera made by a medium and upload 15 photos.
OK.
You guys don't try this though.
On me I mean.
It has to be of a loved one.
He will then receive a message from the spirit.
I don't know if I can really trust this, but it's the only way.
Oh.
I was one of the lucky few who got a hold of this special camera.
And I was relieved to know that my girl could finally rest in peace.
My girl.
OK.
We got the actual...what's the...camera obscura.
We got the camera obscura.
Why did we wake up face down in the toilet?
What?
I'm sure it will work if I try on you.
No, it won't.
Why did we wake up here?
Long night dad, huh?
I'm assuming we're dead.
I don't know.
Mom?
Dad?
Parent?
Parental figure?
OK.
I don't like the ship to run.
But it's fine.
Take a picture.
Check your photos.
Oh, nothing.
Oh, space party.
OK.
So we're like taking...
I found one.
Guardian, yeah.
MK, welcome to the membership.
Look right there.
Don't like that.
I found one already.
I'm a...wait, close.
Oh my gosh.
I'm a natural, honestly.
OK.
Anything else in here?
Oh, I don't like that you can like pull up the camera and not have the camera.
I just don't like it.
I'm also a vampire.
The paranormal runs in the family apparently.
Oh, it's a nice little park though.
3,
2, 1, 0.
Hello?
Oh no!
Oh, there is a father!
Is this our dead daughter or is this another daughter?
I understand.
Wait, does that mean she's on the phone?
No.
Mickey Mouse!
Michael Moose?
Yeah, that's definitely Mickey Mouse there.
That doesn't even look like a mouse.
Wow,
we're in the game.
We're looking around.
We're looking for spirits of the park.
Couldn't we do this?
Oh, there's children over there.
Couldn't we do this on like a sunnier, nicer day?
Whose boots are these?
Your camera is blocking the subtitles.
I'll move my arm.
No worries.
No worries, no worries.
Oh, wait, hold on.
I'll be armless today.
There we go.
Camera on the head.
That's like my GoPro.
Hello, fellow kids.
I bet there's like a ghost anime in between you two.
Oh my god, there's a ghost!
Oh my god, he's...
Doesn't your back hurt?
He's literally performing...
He's like part of...
He's part of WWE.
He's gonna pull you down.
I don't know if I should be taking pictures of random children.
That's Chicky Chinchilla.
Oh, he's gone.
Is he gonna pop up when I...
Okay, alright.
That's two down.
Two out of fifteen.
Yeah, two out of fifteen.
Nice.
So I guess we should just be looking anywhere, right?
For any sort of paranormal activity.
In the puddle.
In the trees.
Ew, I don't like that place.
In the...
I feel safer without the camera.
I feel safer without it.
Okay, let's go look at those boots, because they were mighty suspicious.
Look!
Oh, it's running.
By itself.
That's suspicious.
Right?
Okay, nevermind.
It's just an artsy photo.
Wait, shouldn't it not be running by itself?
7022... What are the numbers?
The numbers, what do they mean?
Yeah, why is it black water?
It's disgusting.
Children are supposed to drink that.
Okay, let's check out these boots.
These boots are haunted for sure.
Okay.
There's numbers everywhere.
42?
53?
This swing's gotta be haunted.
Am I bad at this?
Why is there no ghosts?
Maybe I should be thankful?
We could just go home.
We could leave.
That would be a really great other...
Oh, Nico!
Thank you for the raid.
Hello, hello.
Chief.
What do we got here?
Mocari sweat.
Strawberry milk.
PPC.
Wow, you can actually read these so clearly.
Never been done before.
Wow, invisible boost!
Thank you so much for the 50.
Give the thank you!
Suspicious bag.
Guys, I think I'm bad at this game.
Tires.
Can you crouch or anything?
No.
Do you guys see anything?
There's numbers everywhere.
Trees.
You also walk so slowly when the camera is up.
Oh my god.
Where did that come from?
A literal tree hugger.
God.
Am I lagging sometimes?
I think the game is a little...
Oh, my daughter.
Okay, 6pm.
Bing bong, bing bong.
That kid has been at it for a while.
Really been scratching...
How do we know the ghost we are taking is of my kid?
I guess we are just assuming that.
This is still going.
I feel it must be haunted.
Oh my god!
Are you my...
Are you my daughter?
It was haunted after all.
How did I miss that?
Okay, cool.
How many have we got now?
We can get rid of this one.
1, 2, 3, 4.
4 out of 15.
Good job, team.
Haunted bench.
Sorry, I thought I heard like a crying or something.
As long as those kids are there, I feel safer.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm like, yeah.
Oh, cute!
Not cute.
Hello, daughter.
Oh god, that looks so haunted in there.
This could have been an email.
Kind of announcement.
Sorry, I've been very busy.
You think her face would appear?
Wait, why are there rocks surrounding it?
Atmosphere is getting to me a little bit.
It's pretty spooky, you guys.
There's numbers everywhere!
Wait, that was last year.
Is this every...
Every year a child is taken?
Is the numbers...
Wait, what was another number?
There was one out here.
Wait, it's...
Gosh.
They will be important.
Oh no, this is another bathroom.
I can't go in here though.
This is that boy's bathroom.
That's gross.
There was number...
Is the smiley still there?
It is.
This is the thumbnail.
Oh, CC.
Oh wait, 4000...
Okay, never mind.
Never mind.
Is this supposed to be a panda or...
This one looks like a koala.
This one looks like a dog.
Maybe a...
A tanuki?
RIP future child.
It's like a... What was that movie?
Where he goes, let me in now.
And it will be nice.
I come back every...
Couple hundred years...
Not one...
Long legs.
See?
24, 26.
Someone... Oh, maybe there's like someone...
Someone will be taken.
I don't see any...
Okay, never mind.
Okay, what about in here?
I see a soccer ball.
No.
Oh, no, no.
It looked like it had a face on it for a second.
I'm too afraid to take out the camera, you guys.
In the tree.
The ghost of a monkey?
Just got off my first day on my new part-time job.
Alright, let's go into the boys' bathroom.
I'm scared.
Oh wait, there's a light on up there.
Can I zoom?
Sorry, I didn't mean to take a picture of your house.
It would have really sucked if there was a lady changing in the window, huh?
Bugred?
Barry!
What the...
Oh, is that me?
Oh, that's my floating camera.
My floating ghost camera.
Look at it.
Spooky!
Take off!
Thanks for the gifted, Andrew!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you, guys.
I do enjoy this ghost.
Have you played this game before?
Oh, we can go up the slide.
Wait, this is a perfect vantage point.
Where we can see all ghosts.
Have you played this game before?
It's kind of scary.
I mean, nothing has happened, but...
Oh my god!
Why did I close my eyes to go down the slide?
Are you a baby?
Just himself.
Thanks for the gifted!
Alright, let's go into the boys' bathroom.
Barry, if I call you...
Do you want to be on call with me?
I'm scared.
I don't mind, really!
Would you?
Is it okay?
Is it okay, you guys?
Barry messaged me.
I'm scared, you guys!
Are we calling Barry Bug?
Barry Bug, help me!
Are you sure?
I'm telling her no pressure.
She doesn't want to join.
I'm scared!
Ravenel, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Ravenel!
Happy birthday!
Okay, I'm gonna call Barry now.
I have to set it up real quick.
Okay, I'll call.
Hello?
Is my thing broken?
Hold on, let me check my...
Oh wait.
Hold on!
I hear you!
Sorry, my mic was...
My mic is destroying itself.
Oh no, I think it was me.
No, it was on me.
I fixed something.
Okay, let me put your foogie.
Oh no, I have to log in the Discord.
Hold on.
Let's not do that.
I'll just do this instead.
Hold on, let me make sure my foogie isn't something weird either.
No, I'm not gonna do the foogie.
Oh wait, I can't do this.
It's only servers.
Oh, this sucks.
Oh, it's over.
It's so over.
Wait, okay, I'm gonna log in the foogie.
Dang it, I have to... What's my email password?
I don't know.
Oh, I got it!
Yay!
Everybody say hi to Berry!
Oh no.
Hello.
Why are you dying?
Sorry to crash your stream.
No!
I'm sorry to ask you to come on because I'm too baby to play this game.
No, I totally understand.
How is Berry's audio, everybody?
Oh.
It's good?
Okay.
Do you want me to stream the game to you?
Yeah.
Wait, I mean, how scary is... Wait, you only started like 30 minutes ago.
Is it like super scary?
It's... Nothing's happened.
No, I totally get it though.
I totally get it though.
Do you?
Okay, I'm streaming the game to you.
The biggest thing about horror games is just like you psych yourself out, man.
The atmosphere is killing me.
Oh man.
Okay, are you ready?
Alright, let's play.
Are we going into the boys bathroom first?
Wait, sorry.
We're in the boys... Okay, so basically we have... Look at Mickey Mouse.
No, what do we call him?
Chunky Chinchilla?
Yeah.
Pickle Mouse?
Michael Mouse?
Oh, Michael?
And so we have our camera and we're trying to take pictures of our dead daughter.
She could be anywhere.
Oh, see!
She's up there!
She's chilling!
Is she moving?
Wait, this game is fucked up.
What the hell?
I know.
It's kind of messed up.
What just happened?
Get out.
What happened?
Why is the music so scary?
What's happening?
Barry, what did you do?
She's coming.
Don't say that!
Barry, you cursed the stream!
It's over.
I gotta head out you guys.
Please don't leave me.
I don't think we can crouch in this game so I guess we just gotta crawl in here with our whole ass body.
Oh look, there's a heart!
I hate like semi-realistic games like this too.
Oh wait, there's kids nearby.
I know, I took a picture of them.
Is that allowed?
I don't know.
Apparently.
Okay, let's see what's this.
Oh, this is a backpack.
Oh, that's kind of messed up.
No, she's just hanging out.
Why is her head in the bag?
She's just hanging out everybody.
Wouldn't it be so fucked up if like...
Sorry.
What were you gonna...
You did this!
No, I didn't do anything!
I'm just here as your emotional support.
Chinchilla!
Oh no, I hate this!
Wait, this is terrible.
Wait, was I supposed to take a picture of them?
I can return home.
I could.
It keeps giving me the option and it's really tempting every time.
Wow, you're so brave.
Wait, but you're a ghost so shouldn't you be like...
This is your alley.
This is your home ground.
You would think...
I just don't deal with these kinds of ghosts, you know?
I deal with...
I hear something.
I'm imagining it in my...
I'm lagging so bad.
Maybe you should stop streaming to me.
It's ok.
I'll watch the stream.
Are you sure?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm hearing lots of noises.
There's a lot going on here.
Ok, I'm gonna stop streaming to you.
Sorry.
No, it's ok.
You're like...
Dude, I started playing... I tried playing Cabin Factory because you were playing it and I was like...
If Mint played it, maybe I can play it.
No, I couldn't play that game.
I seriously couldn't.
Why?
Where's the ghost?
Hello?
Oh god, why is it so loud?
Ok, I just... I have to imagine it in my mind's eye where...
Where you have very messy hair, you have mascara running down your face and that's like spooky.
And then once you have that outfit...
You'll be so brave.
What are you rambling about?
Sorry, I got caught up in my own fantasy, I think.
There's gotta be something haunted in this house.
I was so right.
How many more do I need?
You have that sense.
I do.
Well, it was red.
It just seemed like, you know...
Wait, how did your kid die?
He didn't say!
Why'd the ambiance stop?
Oh, ok, nevermind, it started again.
Oh, this is a chill as art game?
It looks so different, right?
Yeah, what the heck?
So we need 15 photos.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Find my pages.
I have to be strong.
If I'm more scared, then Mint will hug you for comfort.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on a minute.
Are you the type of person that if someone's more scared, you will level up and be awesome?
I'm like...
Are you?
I don't know.
I feel...
Already safer that you're here.
Wow, what the...
She doesn't know that I'm hacking her game so it's more scary.
Don't say that.
Ever since you've gotten here, it's become scarier and scarier.
There's gotta be a ghost here.
What the heck?
This is us using the slide.
Why is it raining in the slide?
Oh my god, I think our daughter drowned.
Because there's been a lot of stuff of her in the water.
Wow, this is just a sequel to Heavy Rain and we just didn't know.
What was your daughter's name?
What was her... It started with an M.
I'm not sure.
Jason.
Wait, is Jason or Sean Heavy Rain?
It's both.
Do you think there's something in here now?
I'm too scared.
I believe in you.
It's just a hole.
That hole was made for you.
It was definitely not.
Let's see.
I haven't really been over here.
There's a bunch of papers over there.
I'm too afraid to explore.
Oh, this is now stinky.
I like your delayed reaction.
I don't like the chunky chinchilla guy that's around.
That's actually scary.
I don't like him either.
Oh, I'm lagging again.
Sorry, everybody.
The game's not lagging.
Just me.
Okay, guys.
Optimization is a lost art.
Oh, we have another... I know, right?
I only feel safe now playing games that are on consoles.
Because I know that they won't lag.
Have you been playing Indiana Jones on consoles?
Yeah.
I started it on my computer and it was so bad that I had to switch to my Xbox.
I'm an everybody gamer.
I think I start lagging every time I'm near a ghost.
It's like an interference, you know?
See, I get better once the ghost is gone.
Damn, the ghost is like a bazillion polygons.
Oh, sweet.
The ghost just hacked the vending machine and gave us a bunch of free drinks.
Oh!
Okay, let's go.
What did we get?
We got all these golden ones.
Oh no, my daughter, she was a caffeine addict.
All she drank was coffee.
I'm afraid we're about to get jumped by this mouse.
No, not for real.
I don't like it.
How many more do we need, Barry?
Aren't you at the beginning of the game?
We only need 15.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12!
Oh my god, that's... how many more is that?
Twelve.
Three more.
Okay, everybody start telling me when I'm lagging and then we'll know that we're by a ghost.
I'm hacking.
I feel it.
Where did the ambiance go?
Okay, it's back.
There hasn't been anything with these guys.
Wait a second.
He has a shadow and then he doesn't have a shadow!
Look at that!
Oh my god, the game is haunted!
I can't tell if that's a glitch or not.
I think it is a glitch.
Wait.
Oh no.
Barry, Barry, Barry...
It wasn't a glitch?
No, no, no.
Calm down.
Red is the color of love.
I'm glitching.
But I don't want to see Chunky Chinchilla.
I don't want to see him.
Look at him in the eye.
He's more scared of you than you are of him.
I don't think that's true.
I think there's something in here but I don't want to see it.
What are they?
Oh my gosh, it's a bunch of drawings of the Chinchilla.
I think... What if he murdered my daughter?
Oh,
I'm glitching again.
There must be something.
I'm checking.
In the trees.
Oh my gosh, I'm too scared to look around.
Okay, anybody tell me if you see something.
It could be a ground ghost.
I don't know.
That's true.
Worms could have ghosts.
The origami killer.
These games are so fun.
When is that guy going to make a new game?
Wait, that's not the same guy that made Detroit become human, right?
It is.
Okay, when is he going to make another one?
You gotta go... Have you ever played Fahrenheit?
Indigo Prophecy.
That one's actually so funny.
You have to play that one.
Fahrenheit.
What's that one about?
It's about a guy who gets possessed.
Sorry.
What happened?
Oh, I see him.
I see him.
Oh, come on.
I got a better picture than that.
He's kind of cute.
Like, in a fucked up way.
This is actual cursed photography.
I don't want that anymore.
I don't even remember what it had.
I just remember laughing so hard.
You need to play it.
Okay.
I believe you.
There's gotta be something with these boots.
Maybe you have to look above?
So, maybe they're like...
Oh, you're so big-brained.
And you were wrong.
Your brain means nothing.
Well, I'm trying, okay?
I'm trying.
I am too.
I'm trying and I'm crying.
I wanna return home.
It's so tempting.
You get the bad ending then?
If you return home?
I have no idea.
I feel like it's a waste if you go home now.
True.
You're so close.
I know.
We only have two left.
Anything here?
Am I lagging?
No?
Full proof Vtuber plan.
If you lag, then there's a ghost around.
If you were a chinchilla, where would you be hiding?
A chinchilla?
Yeah, like the chinchilla guy?
Don't the chinchillas stay in the trees?
I don't actually know.
Where do chinchillas...
Where do they live?
Like they are... I know they have to be in dust.
But other than that...
Okay, we got that area.
I don't know.
Maybe something with the tires.
Oh wait!
Is that a body part?
What's that sound?
I hear something.
Barry, I'm too afraid to turn around.
He's right behind me.
Don't say that!
Oh, Ashton!
Hi, Ashton.
I'm sorry, we don't know anything about chinchillas.
Yeah, sorry, Ashton.
Maybe you could educate us...
on your cleaning habits.
Maybe this bench or...
You're not supposed to go to the red area.
I went to the red area, right?
Oh, I thought it got more concentrated.
I don't think so.
Oh god, my eyes.
I think it's because we stand here, our eyes get adjusted to it.
Maybe?
I don't know.
I think we just get our... How many photos is that now, guys?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14!
Just one more!
Okay, okay, okay, lock in, lock in!
Lock in!
Uh...
If I were a ghost, I would be in a tunnel.
But I got a picture of the tunnel earlier.
Okay!
Boogers, I'm a ghost in the tunnel!
It's just a ball?
Tell me it's just a ball!
The delay is...
Sorry everybody, I can't cast to bury because...
It makes me lag even more.
Unoptimized game, please understand.
It's a delayed punch, man.
I know.
But you'll know that something's coming.
Thank you for being my shield.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Maybe the bench?
Any chinchillas here?
I can't tell if I'm supposed to be taking pictures of him or not.
I don't think it counts.
I think he's just there to mess you up.
I think so too.
They're here to throw off my groove.
Yeah.
He's about to cease and desist you.
Actual Disney.
He's coming!
I don't know where...
I think I'm just in mud.
More numbers!
5, 9, 6, 4...
I'm in a soup.
What could it mean?
That was such a bore.
I saw...
I saw earlier that someone was...
It was like a clip that was like, Barry gets tricked into playing P.T.
No!
Oh my god, I don't want to ever play P.T.
But the amount of times that people just reference it in other games is insane.
Have you played P.T.?
No!
Play it!
I saw you and Matara were playing it.
I was like, oh my god.
You're like forcing Matara like Clockwork Orange style to play it.
Yeah!
Clockwork Orange style.
Yeah, come over, you can play it.
No!
I can come over for other reasons too, right?
No.
Do you think I can call the number at the...
5, 9, 6, 4...
Okay, she's kind of smart with it.
Because this doesn't...
Oh, you can!
This little bitch.
That was the last one!
I'm gonna drown.
Game over.
No, no, no, Harry Houdini can get out.
You can get out too.
Harry Houdini is dead!
No, but he died for other reasons.
Oh, it's raining!
Oh gosh, it's really hard to see.
Okay, the darkness is taking over the playground, so I think I'm gonna leave.
Bye!
You will not be able to return...
Oh, thank God, we will not...
Oh my God, game over!
I think we did it.
You got a game over?
We go back home, that's a game over, right?
But, did you do it?
Did you solve the mystery?
So now we have to take our photos and we have to upload them to the dark web.
Yeah.
So we auto-select all of them.
This warning feels kind of ominous.
The photos must be taken within 13 days after the death.
What if she died before?
Well, I guess it's over then, huh?
Maybe.
Hold on, I'm gonna get rid of this spammer.
Go away!
How long ago did she die?
I don't...
They said she went missing.
It's over.
I don't remember.
It was like yesterday.
Larry?
Oh my gosh, do you know Offline?
No?
Okay, you don't know Larry.
I don't know Larry, I'm sorry.
You don't know scariest stories, try not to be scared.
No, I don't know anything, man.
Okay, I'm gonna send you all the videos after this.
Okay, thank you.
You don't know the meat worm, you don't know Larry, you don't know...
I know the creatures, wait, like the YouTube group?
No, who?
Oh, wait, shit, nevermind.
Who's the YouTube group?
There's a YouTube group called the Creatures, but I don't know if we're on the same...
Ashton just fucking sent me a crotch... a pants grab, what the hell?
Ashton, I hate you.
Like, vulgin?
Vulgin?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, she just vulgined me.
Okay, I upload these pictures now.
You upload, you upload.
I'm uploading?
Woah, we're on old-school internet.
Holy...
It's gonna take one minute, 40, 30, 20 seconds, 21... fastest internet ever.
Ew, why do I have a foot... what is this?
Oh, this is like the Slenderman...
Wait, I didn't know you were taking video.
We didn't take video.
Why is this Jaws music?
Oh, it's before.
You were having so much fun...
Why would you take a video of your kid going to the bathroom?
What is wrong with my game?
I think it's glitched.
Oh, there's a person in my apartment.
Yeah, you, right?
Guys, this doesn't seem normal.
This doesn't seem like it should be happening.
What do you mean?
The iconic black goop.
Wait, yeah, I think your game is kind of...
I think my game is broken.
Sorry for bugging out, you guys.
Ew, look, there's literally bugs in my apartment.
Get out of it, Taricon.
What are you talking about?
That bug is climbing up the air.
Okay, I...
This is sick and twisted.
I see, I see...
Oh my god, he's coming towards us.
I see how you feel now.
It's okay.
Squash.
Squish-squash.
Okay, well, I'm just gonna try and get through the darkness, everybody.
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh my god.
Okay, this black goo is kind of intense.
I know, it's hard.
It says she's still here.
Do I go through here?
Okay, it doesn't open.
Do I go through this?
Look on OBS preview.
Don't look at your game.
Yeah, true, true, true.
Should I reload?
If I quit though, will I have to start the game over?
I don't... Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know if it's saved.
I don't know either.
Try the camera.
Well, thank you, Mint, for playing this game and letting me join it.
Now I don't have to play this game myself.
Yippee!
Yeah, you're welcome!
Is there a ghost in there?
Oh, that's my daughter!
What's going on?
I don't like this.
I don't like it.
They're telling you to turn off your graphics AI settings.
But I don't know what the...
Graphics AI settings.
Where do I find that?
I had to put everything on high.
Because I was like... Oh, maybe the shadow maps.
Disable black fog.
That's not even an option.
I don't know what to put it on.
Well, obviously the guy...
You guys are liars!
The Wisps are liars!
They're liars!
What else is new?
I don't know.
I'm gonna turn off the shadow maps.
See if that helps.
Maybe?
No.
It's still pretty intense.
That's just your roommate.
He has like a lot of aura.
Yeah, we got that.
Yeah, he's got that real energy.
You can feel it.
Yeah.
Upscaling?
Oh, turn off upscaling?
Oh, like this.
Let's try.
Did it work?
No.
Well, we gave it a chance.
I can go inside now.
Damn, did you live like this?
Welcome to my house.
You can stay anywhere.
Oh, I thought that was a stain, but thank...
I hear a sound.
Get out of the air!
No wonder it's stinky in here.
Hiding bodies in the air.
What am I supposed to do with...
Oh, there's numbers here too!
Okay, so I'm having to take 15 more photos?
4209.
I just heard someone flush the toilet.
Maybe this is your job, you just go to these places and take photos and then go home and then...
I don't know.
I thought it was about your daughter dying.
He's got some long, long arms.
Some teeny tiny hands.
Little T-Rex over here.
Don't make fun of his hands.
Sorry, it was kind of...
Was that there before?
Oh, it wasn't.
Did you ever do that?
Hell yeah!
See, this game isn't scary.
There's a fan, there's a...
Use your Wii points!
Oh wait, there's another number.
Yeah, there's this number and this number.
I hear something.
Like crackling.
Maybe here?
Oh, it's just this bug.
Why'd you say it like that?
I don't know.
Oh, the stream is like stuttering a little bit.
No way!
This game is so cursed in more ways than one!
I swear, this is my last ever Chilla's Art game.
I can't do this anymore.
You're just exposing your potato PC.
What?
I just got this PC!
I literally just bought every new part.
It's completely new.
It's not good enough for Chilla's Art!
Trill.
Triple A Gaming over here.
Oh god.
I'm hearing bugs everywhere.
What the hell?
Can you stop saying that?
That's hurting my feelings.
Sorry.
I'm hearing someone flush the toilet!
Sorry, that was me.
Then don't flush it, Batuu!
Oh.
I just...
I just leave it?
At least they're clean.
Is there someone in here?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
But someone's flushing the toilet!
You're so brave!
You're so brave and awesome!
You're so beautiful and brave and awesome!
And your brain is so green and so wrinkly!
Okay, no one's in there.
Someone in the mirror?
No one.
Oh, it's my daughter's room.
Mitsuka.
I'm hearing...
I'm hearing flies.
Is the body still in there?
There's bodies everywhere.
Oh my gosh, those shadows are scaring the heck out of me.
Someone said keep looking at the toilet.
What?
Oh, see?
It flushed, it flushed, it flushed!
Oh, it flushed?
Did you know...
Did you know all mammals take around 21 seconds to pee?
Really?
Yeah, so next time you go to the bathroom, you should time it.
And send it to me.
Okay.
Yeah, I'll do that.
I'll get the stopwatch out even.
I'll give you the most accurate numbers.
Down to the millisecond.
Yeah, yeah.
You should keep a log.
The toilet is supposed to be a safe...
Oh, I see a ghost up there.
Did you see her?
Oh shit, I did, I did, I am, I am right now.
Oh, she's just chilling.
Did you guys see it?
She was up in the corridor.
I'm gonna take a picture of her and I'm gonna close my eyes.
Stay strong, stay strong.
She looks real freaky.
Why?
That's not my dot.
Oh, what happened to her?
Oh, maybe she's camera shy.
Oh god.
Maybe.
What?
The toilet's still going.
Ghost?
You look like ghosts to you?
The toilet ghost.
Actually, there's a song about that.
Oh yeah?
It's about a toilet kamisama.
And it's about... check the door.
That's the ghost I just...
She's literally opening it up and flushing the toilet.
Holy shit.
Wait, isn't that just like the really technologically advanced automatic toilets?
Yeah.
I think that's just how they work.
Actually, I think that's literally just how they work.
It's not automatic at all.
It's just someone living inside the toilet that reaches out.
Don't look behind the curtain, everybody.
There's always a man behind the magic.
How many photos do I need?
1, 2, 3, 4... I have 6.
Do I need 15 again?
It looks like maybe?
Oh, what's in here?
Okay, we can't go in there.
Oh my gosh, I just hear creepy crawlies everywhere.
Can I leave?
Let's go into my daughter's room.
Okay, I can't.
Into the kitchen?
This is actually such a nice place.
Uh, there?
Oh, little toes.
She thinks we can't see her.
What a dumbass.
I know.
World's worst hide-and-seek champion right there.
I'm scared to look around.
Okay, it's okay.
I don't think there's any jumpscares here.
So I don't think this is a jumpscare game.
Yeah, I guess you're right.
I feel like it should be though.
I feel like it's luring us into a false sense of...
security.
No, no, no, you just gotta believe.
Also, that's a lot of beer.
Oh, this is beer.
I thought it was the coffee.
From the vending machine.
I think it's beer, isn't it?
Asahi Super.
Yeah, we get that Asahi Dry.
What else?
In the fridge?
Why can't I see anything?
Dude, that's my gripe with a lot of these games.
I don't have a good dark vision, so I'm just legitimately blind.
For so much of it.
Yeah.
I even turned up the brightness.
Oh, goodness.
Turn the brightness up.
Maybe we do a little bit more because we have the...
The... what's it called?
Let's try 3.1.
That didn't do much, I think.
Who's the fredman?
My name is Matara Khan.
Yeah, I'm a bug.
Yeah.
Thanks, Matara, for being here.
You're the much more tolerable...
Tolerable Matara Khan.
Wait, don't say that.
She's actually gonna kill me.
Oh, you think maybe the TV.
That would be kind of spooky.
Anything?
No?
Okay.
Nothing outside, really?
I knew it.
Yeah, I guess you just have to think about like...
Stereotypical places, maybe?
Stereotypical what?
Ghost places?
Like where they would usually be, maybe?
Yeah.
Oh, let's try...
I didn't... Oh, gosh.
There's a lady!
There's just a regular lady!
That's just a regular lady!
I don't have the camera!
Pina?
Pina.
Should I take a picture of her?
I knew I thought you said your camera was...
Oh my god.
Why is she...
Ma'am, I think you're too old for that uniform.
She says you're never too old to cosplay.
Yep, eternally 18.
She's actually such an iconic queen.
She's just a normal person.
I think she's maybe...
I think that's even worse that there's just a normal person in my house.
Maybe you left the door open.
Oh god, I'm so embarrassed.
It's so smelly in here.
And we have like a massive shadow problem.
This is so...
Wait, that's true.
Oh my gosh, she's gonna see how shadowy and terrible my house is.
It's not normally like this.
Oh god.
Yeah, I just let myself go this weekend.
It's just, you know, I played a lot of Kingdom Hearts.
The darkness is coming in.
Okay, should I walk to her?
I think you have to, right?
Okay, I'm gonna close my eyes and I'm gonna run.
What's happening?
I don't know.
That scared me.
Oh, she came at me really slowly.
It's like she was approaching a small animal.
Don't worry.
It was really like that.
Maybe they really are more afraid of us than I am of them.
Yeah.
You're the real ghost here.
True.
Why is the music getting weird all of a sudden?
I wanna try and put in one of these numbers.
We have 4209 everybody.
But I'm scared what if that lady comes back?
It'll be okay.
Who is she?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, the phone was there.
Make sure you close the door from the kitchen to the hallway.
Kitchen to the hallway.
Oh my god.
The door just shut by itself.
Why?
No, it's okay.
That was just me.
That was me.
I'm your roommate.
Sorry.
Okay.
The kitchen to the hallway.
This one?
It's like little hints.
There it is.
Neat.
Wait, so then, does that number then go away?
It's gone.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
So the numbers that are left are just...
The numbers that are left are pictures I haven't taken of yet.
Was the one on the picture frame still there?
Picture frame?
This one?
Oh, yeah.
3617.
Okay.
We're gonna do it.
Wow, the ghosts are so helpful.
I know, right?
3...
6...
1...
7.
The bugs behind the fridge are disgusting.
Where did they even come from?
I noticed there was more bugs than normal there.
You're cheating on me.
Look at all these bugs.
They're all inhabiting my home.
Like here?
You're a bug magnet.
Oh my god.
Her texture is a little broken, but that's okay.
She's still spooky.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, it was broken.
Yeah.
How many more?
9...
10...
11.
Oh, we're close!
I don't remember seeing any other numbers, you guys.
Uh...
I think someone said to check the closet before, but I don't know if that's still like...
The closet.
This one?
Closet.
It's kind of...
I don't know.
Maybe the one that's like the doorway?
Like the walk-in one?
This one over here?
Hold on, I'm loading.
Someone said there's one on the couch.
Couch.
Okay, next person to lie in chat will get their hair...
Bad luck for 7 years.
Yeah, yeah.
I was gonna say I'm gonna rip their hair off, but yeah.
You can choose your preference.
Oh,
on the wall?
Where on the wall?
There's like...
We're in a house, there's walls everywhere.
Here?
That's true.
There's no ghost.
I can't tell what's a ghost and what's a shadow.
I know, everything is a shadow.
Oh, this closet.
Oh, it's kind of cracked open, right?
Oh gosh, I'm scared of this.
Oh, there's a number.
Oh, 6834.
Wait, is there anything in this corner?
Is that a ghost or...
Oh, what is that?
Something shiny in there.
I'll take a picture.
Wait, once it shows...
No, I think it's just a texture thing.
What was the number?
Six...
Sorry.
Oh, 6834.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Did you get that from chat or did you...
No.
Why do they keep shutting the door?
Stop it.
I am very helpful, guys.
Six...
Eight...
Three...
Four...
The inside of the table is warm.
Okay, the kotatsu.
Yeah.
Or this table.
I don't know.
I don't think it's that one.
Oh, maybe here.
Oh god.
I don't know.
Where?
Kotatsu?
I can't crouch or anything, so...
Oh.
What was that?
Just my kid being a freaking weirdo.
What's that sound?
It's me.
What is that sound?
I don't know.
I've been stream muted, sorry.
What?
I don't wanna hear it.
I think someone's doing my dishes.
Oh, I can't get my camera out anymore.
Wait, why not?
Is the lady at the front door again?
Oh no, no.
I can't get the camera.
I don't know.
Maybe it's in my daughter's room.
It's like a...
Here, just listen.
Oh, I do hear it.
It's like an earthquake type.
Everything is going crazy.
Everything is going crazy in this.
My whole house is haunted.
Yeah, you're in it.
Ehhh!
Cutscene!
Oh my god!
Chunky Chinchillas in my house!
Sorry.
I don't like mascot stuff like that.
What happened?
You're so brave.
You're so brave, Mint.
You're so brave and awesome.
You can do this.
One foot.
Oh,
is it like Fatal Frame?
Are you like pushing him back with the camera?
I think so.
Oh no!
Come on!
I'm stuck in a corner.
This is perfect.
Come at me!
Come at me, Chunky!
Chungus!
Chinchilla!
Ashton!
Don't call Ashton that.
Ashton Martin!
I don't know what I'm supposed to do.
I don't know...
Maybe you're supposed to like walk around.
How am I supposed to walk around with this freakazoid coming at me?
I wonder what happens if he touches me.
Is the game over?
Maybe.
Uncanny.
Chingu!
I hear...
He was running!
I heard him go...
I heard his little feet!
He's running at me again.
I hear him.
Come on.
It's like thunder and lightning.
Come here!
I'm not moving from this corner.
You can't make me!
I can't tell if I'm doing this right.
Wait, should I look up a guide?
I don't know.
Wait, hold on.
I hear him.
He's running again.
I can't...I can't do this.
He's got a chainsaw!
Hold on.
Just get in your ass and run!
I don't know if I can keep going this way.
I just might.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
He's not wearing pants, Barry!
He's not wearing pants!
I hear him.
This is the boss fight, I think.
It is?
With his...
Oh my god, I think he's running at me again.
I don't know.
Maybe it is the boss fight.
I got an achievement!
Finish the boss fight without dying!
Oh, you did it!
Wait, so you were...
I didn't know you were a gamer like that.
I gamed.
You're a gamer.
Oh my god.
Wait, he's doing my strat.
He's sitting in the corner.
The AI learns from you.
No, no.
I can't move.
I can't move even.
Oh, hello.
What's happening?
What's happened?
Why is there blood all in my room?
I mean my daughter's room.
She's a weirdo.
She's got anime girls all over her wall.
She's just like me.
I know.
We beheaded him.
We beheaded the Chungus.
Take that Chungus chinchilla.
That was scripted though, right?
I think so.
Oh, I don't have my camera anymore.
Oh, it's Henya.
Oh, it's the supporters, right?
Yeah.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
I remember seeing people saying there's Doki.
Oh, there she is.
Yeah.
Oh, I do like... Oh, that's why it was like crayon.
What?
Because it's your daughter's room.
Perry, you didn't tell me you were in the game.
Dog, I've never... Don't ever call me for help again.
I can't believe this.
Wait, what is this then?
Damn, sexy lady.
Is that my daughter?
Oh, she really liked the Chungus man.
And then she hated him.
Yeah, we killed him.
Yeah, we killed him with the power of...
Friendship.
Friendship?
I don't know about that.
Do I leave or...
Oh, yeah, I guess this is the end.
I said final boss.
Yeah.
And I don't have a camera anymore.
I don't have my camera, you guys.
Where's the...
But...
I don't have my camera and also I said I beat the final boss, so where's the ending of the game?
No, no, no.
You're playing as your daughter and you probably woke up in the middle of the night and now it's time to watch Inuyasha on Adult Swim.
You're so right.
Here we go.
We're playing on the computer in the darkness.
We're full gamer mode.
Upload a ghost photo.
What?
There's more?
No, no, no.
These are not the photos I took.
Oh, you gotta help your daughter find her way back to the spirit world.
If they made that into a plushie, would you get it?
Oh, no.
You're crazy.
You sure?
You said you kind of liked him.
No, I never said that.
What are you talking about?
You're putting words in my mouth.
You want me to blatantly lie on the internet?
What the heck?
I thought the photos looked different.
Yeah, these are not the photos we took.
We must really like this one photo of our daughter.
Yeah.
It's divisible by 5.
I like 15 as a number, you know?
Press the camera icon.
You can't.
You like 15 as a number?
Yeah, 15 is a pretty good number, right?
Do you just say anything?
Who says that?
That's a good number.
What the heck?
You're so judgmental.
Nah, I like 14.
Okay.
Okay, I'm uploading this to the internet.
2015 is when Metal Gear Solid 5 came out, so what if I like it because of that, huh?
Valid.
So, actually, so real.
I'm a believer now.
You convinced me.
Yeah, 15 is a good number.
Violation.
Damn,
we procrastinated too much.
I hate these damn... You can't go on any site anymore.
If you have an adblocker, the internet... If you don't have an adblocker, the internet is literally impossible.
Yeah.
This is like you go to any news website.
It's just like boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Man.
That's why we're sponsored by Minto Explorer.
There's an adblocker.
Oh, another video.
Someone's walking from the bedroom.
Hello, daughter.
She's really slow.
Also, where is dad's room?
Where do we sleep?
Can I move?
No, I can't move around.
On the couch, yeah, I guess so.
Oh my god, she's like sliding backwards a little bit.
She was moonwalking to the...
She's a big fan of Michael Jackson.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, she accidentally touched the phone of death.
It's the phone that kills you.
Don't do it, Mitsuka.
What?
She took the phone and played the brown note immediately.
Oh no.
Oh, that's...
What happened?
She just died?
Wait, what just happened actually?
Yeah, we never should have installed the phone that kills you.
I know.
What?
Why is there more?
No!
I don't have my camera.
Are you sure it said final boss on the achievement?
It did!
It said final... Oh, our fan is gone.
Why is that the part that we clean up?
I'm so confused.
Wait, all the... Oh no, I was gonna say all the trash is gone.
No...
Hello?
Who do you think it is?
Yeah, it's... Pizza?
Pizza?
Oh my gosh, that's like the other... There's another Chilla's art game where you play as a pizza person.
Oh, right.
Imagine if they were connected.
That'd be insane.
Yeah, it might be.
The Chilla's art extended universe.
Oh god, I'm scared.
No, it's just a book.
No, it's a missing poster.
Oh no, it's just a book.
It's not a book.
Oh god.
Manami Kodan?
What?
That's not our daughter.
That's not our daughter?
What the...
They really want to hammer it home that that's not your daughter's name.
What's going on?
Oh god.
Can I leave?
What's going on?
I don't have my camera.
Where do I go?
Go to the door.
This one?
The supporters.
The supporters will help me.
Keep looking at Henya.
Oh, the phone's ringing.
Yeah, keep looking at Henya.
Hello?
Wait, it's the phone that kills you.
Don't do it dad!
You were
watching when she said this earlier, right?
Oh no.
She said that there was a phone call in the park earlier.
It was the same conversation.
I see.
Bloody bathroom.
You know what I will say?
I feel like Japan has such nice...
Or like most places...
Because Japan likes the really big tubs.
I love that.
Oh yeah, the camera now.
I don't think I want the camera.
So that's the missing girl that's not our daughter?
So you have a different kid?
Wait, I think we murdered the other girl.
We killed her in the bathtub.
But also, Japan does not have big bathtubs.
They kind of suck actually.
Really?
I feel like...
Maybe I have a skewed opinion because all I do... I'm just a weeb.
I think it really depends on what kind of place you get.
Wait, what the hell?
That's my daughter!
Wait, what?
I
think I'm frozen here.
I'm frozen in fear.
Hug your daughter!
I love you daughter and your polka dot pyjamas.
We
eat hamburgers in the tub.
How many times do I have to tell you?
Oh, are we going to watch her die?
She's calling...
Oh, the police.
The police?
Yeah, the girl was killed by...
Berry, we were the bad guy.
We were the bad guy all along!
Wait, why are you saying we?
Hey, I'm not...
Berry, we were the bad guy.
No, wait, hold on.
I didn't do anything though.
Berry, you are complicit in this.
Me?
Yeah, you were here the whole time.
No.
I like how it was just like, hey, you want to get through the ending?
No, no, no, don't speed up.
Oh, that's fast.
Oh, I hear the police.
Okay, so what?
We killed the girl and then our daughter snitched us.
Yeah.
So we killed our daughter?
I think that's it.
But then why were we trying to bring her back?
Oh, wait, true.
Well, maybe we were haunted by...
I can't tell if we killed her because she was on the phone and then just collapsed.
And then we came in and were like, what's wrong?
Maybe that's how we got her.
Maybe.
Oh, we can look in here.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Sorry guys, it's so loud.
I'm confused a little bit.
Her daughter had a concussion from playing in the park with her friend.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Is that confirmed knowledge?
Well, because she said her head was like...
Oh, it was hurting, yeah.
Oh, the daughter had an accident in the park while playing with her friend and the dad blamed that friend.
You'll never take me alive!
I'm gonna go into the toilet that Isekai-zu.
Yes, yes.
Do I have to answer the door?
Do I have a gun?
You gotta turn yourself in.
Ah, it's Japan.
It's only right.
Minto, it's only right.
Ah, man.
No more Inuyasha for you.
You gotta go to jail.
One more episode, mom, please!
I want to change the world!
One ending.
There's only one ending.
That's what the achievement I just got.
Oh, wait.
I'm running for it.
Oh, you mean to dash for it?
Oh, damn!
I really am just a coward.
Oh my god!
Oh, nevermind.
Oh, bye!
It keeps going.
He did a flip.
Oh, so did she.
She was so stiff.
Oh, wait.
What the... Wait, what's going on?
Oh my god, I think Chungus and Chilla just picked up the...
Wait, do you think we were the...
What did the Chilla... What did that guy have to do with it?
What's going on?
Oh, this was made in Unreal.
No wonder it's like a little...
Oh, man.
Me when Metal Gear Solid Delta was announced for Unreal.
Wow, we did it!
Oh, spooky, scary game.
But who was Phone?
Who was Phone?
Chinchilla.
Who was the old lady?
Oh, wait.
You're right.
Who was that?
It's just some random ass lady.
I guess it was really the landlord.
But who was lady?
Hand or hook car?
The landlord saw us like tweaking out and she was just like, okay, I'm out.
I'll come back another time.
Who was that?
Clearly, yeah, it was MataraCon.
Coming to try and join in on the game club.
Yeah.
Well, that was fun.
Thank you for having me.
No, I don't think I would have been able to beat the game.
I wouldn't have been able to do this without you, Perry.
Wow.
Wow, we're in love with each other.
You're in love with me.
Don't say anything.
Let's not go so far.
Don't say anything, please.
Thank you for having me.
I'm sorry to barge in.
No, I asked you to come.
Yeah, but any wisps that are angry at me, you could send an email to me.
No one would be because I'm just a baby with these games.
With the cabin place, I couldn't even listen to it with headphones.
I had to take out my headphones.
Oh, you don't watch that, Vaude.
No, you don't.
Did you call for the jump scare thing?
Which one?
The one that was like in the settings, the jump scare on and off thing.
What?
In cabin factory, in the settings, there's like a setting for jump scares on and off and it's on off.
And if you turn it on, it like just immediately jump scares you.
No way!
Did you not get caught?
Wait.
Nobody told me.
You didn't do that?
What?
Wait, you guys are slacking.
What the heck?
Maybe they do love me.
No, you guys.
You guys are so sweet.
My chat like told me to do that almost immediately.
Why would you be like, oh yeah guys, I'll turn the jump scares on.
That sounds like a better way to play the game.
They were like calling me a coward for having it off and I was like, I didn't even turn it on.
I can't believe this.
I was literally shivering in my booties though.
I couldn't do anything in that game.
I was so scared.
I gotta watch it then.
No, you don't.
No, don't worry.
It was like right before the concert too, so I was already nervous.
Like the one in Atlanta, so I was just like...
You were jittering.
I was.
And then I saw you.
You did.
We saw each other.
We did.
Wow.
I totally don't remember what happened.
I'm just so like...
It's out of my brain now.
Was that good of an experience?
It was awesome.
It was freaking awesome.
Freaking awesome.
It was freaking epic!
Thank you for having me.
Bye everybody!
Bye!
Thanks Mary!
Freaking epic!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, thank you Mary for being here.
I seriously wouldn't have been able to complete the game, I think, without you being here.
So I really appreciate you.
I'll update the title and everything.
And have her socials and stuff for everybody who's like, who dat?
That's just my friend.
I think this is our first ever quote-unquote collab.
Well no, on my channel at least.
We collabed before on Ashton's channel and we talked about theme parks and stuff.
Uncursing funds.
Yeah, the Disney collab.
She multi-streams on YouTube?
She does?
Oh, I didn't know that.
Mary totally says awesomesauce.
I should ask.
Did you say awesomesauce?
That one was spooky.
That one, I like the...
The what's it called?
I like the atmosphere of this one.
Try Princess?
Thank you!
I like the atmosphere of this one.
Henya, I didn't know.
What if I became a supporter too and then they put our pictures right next to each other.
Oh wait, supporter of Henya.
Wait, this isn't actually Henya?
Henya squad.
Look, this one, this literally could have been me in our papers.
Could have been touching.
Get away plague daddy!
Plague mommy, that's me!
Not Henya, hentai.
Yeah, it's the hentai.
Helsing game?
I think I remember seeing this person before.
Don't worry guys, for Delta I'll probably not be playing it on my PC.
So, I'll play it on console so that we can not have any lagging issues.
Don't worry.
Yeah, Doki is here too.
We saw her earlier.
Doki bird.
I'm actually gonna update her.
She's the same, but flipped.
She's number three!
Wait, which number is Henya?
Number one!
No, I'll never be next to her!
This is so funny.
Oh, I like everybody who puts their cats.
Damn.
Okay.
Okay, Nako.
Some good advertising there.
I like how it's just this lady.
I like the little tiny stickers too.
They're fun.
They're fun too.
Oh, it doesn't...
Oh, you can try to open it, but it doesn't open.
That's kinda freaky actually.
Can I open the door?
No.
We're just in the lonesome...
This is such a sad...
Sad room for a little kid.
Oh, here you're wearing pants, but for me you're like, this is a special occasion.
Pants off, baby.
Ollie is here.
Ollie?
That's not Ollie.
Ollie.
Ollie?
I missed her!
Cute!
Went by Google.
I like how it's cute when it's a fan that puts their favorite in the game.
So you have a henya.
RIP Google.
It was so dark and messed up even for Chilla's game.
My theory could be...
Is Mickey...
Wait.
Is Mickey the manifestation of your guilt?
I could be completely wrong.
Could be, because she really likes him.
Right?
He passed away last year.
This was the last gift from Google for Ollie.
This?
Google was a fan of Ollie that passed away.
That's so sad.
That's so sweet.
And Ollie played.
I'm sure she saw.
That's so sweet.
That makes me so emotional.
No, no!
And then...
That was probably such a shock to see too.
Ollie cried.
I would too!
She was a big Zomrad.
I remember seeing Ollie in the other games too.
Was it the same person?
Was it the same Google person?
Is it loyal to her?
To her dying breath?
It was the same.
She's been doing it for a long time then.
Oh my gosh.
That's so sad.
What a nice memory.
Always have...
Always have them in the game.
I don't know how to...
The mood.
If I die I'm not leaving you anything.
Okay.
Go to hell.
See you there.
Quit.
That was actually much faster than I expected too.
You can have my cool socks.
I like what they tried to do with the game.
I honestly prefer horror like this where it's a little more subtle.
And it's more of a build up of atmosphere.
Maybe I could see why people would think this is more boring.
But I liked walking around and you would sometimes see Chungus Mouse.
And other than that $2.
If I die you can have my body if you want to.
What would I do with it?
I can't even possess it.
Subtle Chungus.
Yeah, actually there was not really any jump scares in this.
I felt that I kind of cheesed the final boss fight.
But maybe due to fear.
I didn't realize that I could just stand in the corner and be fine.
Yippee!
A win's a win.
So true.
Almost everyone cheeses it.
Okay, good.
I like horror games with subtle lore breadcrumbs like this.
The ending didn't seem so impossible to put together.
At first I was confused but then it was just like, oh, she had a headache.
Her head hurt and then she collapsed because she had the head injury.
And then you kind of find out that maybe the dad lured...
Well, not maybe, I mean the daughter literally said my dad killed my friend.
And then, yeah, head hurted.
And then...
I actually didn't totally dislike this one.
The game puts you in the corner at the beginning of the fight.
I think they wanted it to be that way.
Possibly, but I was like, I just don't want to walk around the house in the dark.
It was too scary.
Yeah, head hurted.
Do you have any ibuprofen?
But no, we never found out who that lady was.
Maybe our wife?
But we never even mentioned a wife.
I don't think we had a wife.
I don't know who that lady was.
It's almost like you were cowering in the corner.
That's exactly what it was.
Minto, you cowered?
Yeah, and I'm proud.
Because I didn't...
I'm a coward and I'm proud.
Did I get all the achievements?
Oh no, I didn't.
Find all mascot.
And then ghost hunter night park.
Take all ghost photos in the park at night time.
So there's more.
And then there's take all ghost photos at the park in the evening.
And then take all ghost photos in the apartment.
We missed actually a lot.
I only got two achievements.
Wait, so we didn't even see all the ghost photos.
That's kind of fun.
Proud of you coward.
Yeah, cowards live.
Cowards live.
Even though I'm already dead.
The phones have a little extra lore.
Like when you call the numbers for the hints.
Interesting.
But I don't want to go back to the spooky park.
In fact, if you would like to see the rest of the ghosts.
You can watch someone or play it yourself.
Yeah, we'd have to call Barry again.
Let me also thank her.
Thank you Barry.
It's my birthday, Peregrine!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Peregrine.
Happy birthday...
I think I could do the daytime one, but I don't think I could definitely do the nighttime one.
I could maybe do the daytime one, but the nighttime one would be impossible for me.
Too much in the house?
Not with that lady?
What happens if she touches you?
I'm so curious.
She came at me.
I'm so like Fatal Frame Brain that if there's a ghost, I take a picture.
It's my birthday, Raptor!
One more time!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Raptor-senpai.
Happy birthday!
And I'm glad you named your plant after me.
What kind of a ghost am I to be afraid of other ghosts?
Okay, it's like how you guys...
Humans are afraid of other humans, right?
You guys are probably more afraid of other humans than ghosts.
You know, I hear that quite often.
Humans are scarier than ghosts, right?
So for me, it's kind of the same.
Where it's just like, I'm more afraid of ghosts because I'm not afraid of humans.
Makes sense.
Exactly.
Fair.
See?
You're scared of girls?
That's a personal problem.
I don't think I can help you with that one.
So...
But you're actually getting over your fear.
Maybe I am...
What's that therapy?
Like immersion therapy?
Exposure therapy?
I'm exposing myself to you.
You're exposing yourself to me.
No, don't do that.
I didn't think that one through.
I'm afraid of no ghosts.
Right.
What should we bust in tonight?
We just did a ghost.
We just did a spooky stream.
Let's bust in.
It's been a long, long time.
First bust in of the new year.
Before we end the stream.
My trip to Japan in June now...
Consists of three lives in a row.
With Hashino Sora, Liela and Awkwards.
Oh my god.
I can't wait to destroy my voice.
What a stacked lineup.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Bust in.
Bust in makes me feel good.
It's loading?
Why is it taking...
Can you mix this better?
Let
me tell you something.
There is something weird about sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Bust in makes me feel good.
Thank you guys for the stream.
Bust in!
Torahin, Rintou, Seri, Yamashita, Bust in!
Invisible man.
Sleeping in your bed.
Let me tell you something...
Bust in!
Bust in makes me feel good.
Feel good!
Happy Lunar New Year!
Freaky Ghostmade!
Freaky Ghostman!
Freaky man, baby!
Thanks, Fakeny!
If you're all alone, let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good!
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky Ghostbed!
Yeah!
Busted!
Makes me feel good!
See you guys!
Thanks guys!
See you later!
Bye bye!
See you!
Thank you!
Bye bye!
See you later!